présélectionné par un magasin d'une
chaîne de grande distribution isabel
dréan est convoqué pour un rendez vous
avec le directeur elle a alors 49 ans
est en recherche d'emploi depuis une
année un entretien classique et arrive
la question
une question auquel je ne m'attendais
pas mon âge je volontairement je ne
marquais plus mon âge sur mon cv parce
que je sais que ça pouvait créer des
discriminations et c'était dix jours
avant mon anniversaire et je lui annonce
que je vais avoir 40 9 en est là ce son
visage se ferme et il m'a dit
c'est un blocage on n'embauche pas les
personnes âgées et les yeux et vous êtes
trop vieille l'entretien se conclut sur
cette phrase il avait le dréan et
d'abord stupéfaite fait quelques mètres
en voiture et se met à pleurer en se
sentant humilié un hasard fait qu'une
annonce de la plate forme anti
discrimination passe à la radio elle la
contacter pour elle mais aussi pour les
autres ce que j'attendais c'était
d'abord une oreille pour écouter
c'est un service de l'état de donc je
sais que eux ils ont les arguments pour
contrôler pour
faire cesser ce genre de choses convoqué
est épinglé le cas échéant tes mauvaises
pratiques est ce ce que j'attendais si
c'est que ils fassent remonter
l'information
au plus haut de sept chaînes ans après
un échange avec isabel dréan le
défenseur des droit adresse un courrier
qu'a rappel à la loi ce qu'elle vit
comme une victoire elle travaille
aujourd'hui dans une entreprise du monde
aéronautique